[Music]
in this balloon is a fart will be firing
up this high-powered laser downrange
towards our balloon that way we can
safely assess Adams farts can be ignited
by a laser and this is closer than ever
won't my face to Adams flirt
we are shooting farts with lasers for
science let that sink into your heads
how cool is that kind of weird yep weird
science all right this puppy's for real
shooting farts with lasers in three two
one oh my god that was just a balloon
popping I don't think I saw any fire
whatsoever why didn't it work we know
farts are fallible that's a good
question I see two possible explanations
one is that the concentration of methane
in my fart mixture might not be enough
to see a flame or it could be that the
laser doesn't have enough power to
ignite the gas it's just popping the
balloon the most combustible component
of Adam's sin flatus is the methane but
it's only 7% of the total volume so can
the laser ignite a balloon filled with
pure methane all right this is methane
laser explosion maybe hopefully three
two one where's our big explosion once
again the laser pops the balloon but
there's no fireball the laser is
powerful enough to pop the balloon but
not ignite the gas see here the black
matter is our gas escaping into the
atmosphere not on fire what about just
trying a lighter on a balloon full of
the fart mixture versus a balloon full
of methane just to get a cost comparison
Adam suits up to check that the gases
flammability is not what's going to bust
this myth 3 2 1 there we go the methane
fireball confirms it was the laser
failing to ignite the gas okay bring on
one of my farts I want to set some stuff
on fire now and just to be sure that
Adams own output burns too far
dispositioned okay my fart is settled
into the fart holder my hand is on the
lighter let's make some science Adams
asleep thus in three two one that was
good yep the synth latest causes a not
so silent but deadly backdraft